Jean-François Cannes on va plonger dans
votre livre comment on en est arrivé là
aux éditions de l'Observatoire c'est le
récit d'un échec collectif celui d'un
aveuglement sur la montée des extrêmes
politiques intellectuel médias tous
responsables
ça m'a fait réfléchir et ça m'a fait
beaucoup rigoler parce que ça
défouraille et ça il faut le reconnaître
c'est à la fois toujours aussi pertinent
avec de la profondeur historique mais
c'est aussi très piquant et tout le
monde en prend pour son grade on voit
cela dans l'invitation de Maïté Frémont
et on en parle c'est promis juste après
si on vous invite Jean-François Kahn
c'est parce que vous souhaitez
collectivement nous interpeller avec
cette question qui vous obsède tant
comment en est-on arrivé là ceux-là de
votre titre c'est celui d'un
rassemblement national devenu premier
groupe d'opposition à l'Assemblée
nationale et d'une marine Le Pen aux
portes du pouvoir moi je suis très
inquiet on va voir une éradication de la
gauche républicaine et démocratique une
explosion de la droite républicaine et
démocratique une poussée d'extrême
droite qu'on finit on en est même plus
conscient mais plus de vous on vous
aurait dit ça il y a 10 ans plus de 32%
sur les extrêmes droites on vous aurait
dit ça
alors Jean-François Cannes avec la
liberté de vos 85 ans vous prenez une
nouvelle fois la plume pour nous alerter
sur cette tentation des extrêmes qui
risquent selon vous de conduire à la
guerre civile vous l'ancien journaliste
qui est passé par tous les grands médias
presse écrite et radio vous avez aussi
créé votre propre journal L'Événement du
jeudi puis Marianne 10 ans plus tard pas
question de vous taire quitte à ne pas
plaire dans vos 500 pages toute la
classe politique en prend pour son grade
Jaurès remplacé par Mathilde pano
c'était comme si à Eddy Merckx on avait
substitué un enfant colérique monté sur
un tricycle Éric Ciotti se serait voulu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de la droite il n'en
sera que le Benoît Hamon
mais surtout dans votre essai vous
fouillez dans votre mémoire pour trouver
les raisons de cette montée de l'extrême
droite en France en 2022 à la
présidentielle seulement 5 millions de
voix c'est par Emmanuel Macron et Marine
Le Pen contre dix millions cinq ans plus
tôt si le cordon sanitaire plie il ne
seront pas totalement alors une question
ce soir Jean-François Kahn avec ses 500
pages ne jouez-vous pas à nous faire
peur
réponse non parce que ce que je dis
c'est que si on continue à jouer au con
oui nous aurons une victoire de Marine
Le Pen extrême droite mais on n'est pas
obligé de continuer à jouer au con c'est
vrai que je ne vois pas aujourd'hui les
éléments qui me permettent d'espérer
qu'on arrête de jouer au con mais enfin
on peut l'espérer
mon livre c'est pour que ça n'arrive pas
je ne dis pas que ça va arriver quand
même plus de 13 millions de voix pour
Marine Le Pen en 2022 près de 42% des
voix c'est tout simplement inimaginable
même pas 10 ans avant elle prospère elle
progresse sur l'échec de qui sur le
chèque de Tourer 42% pour les extrêmes
droites les extraits
ce qui est inouï c'est qu'on puisse
avoir des sondages montrant que les
extrêmes droites pourraient faire 42% et
que personne ne se pose la question
c'est pas bien
mais en quoi quelle erreur on a commise
comment on en arrive là alors ils disent
les autres c'est Macron c'est la droite
d'accord c'est pas que les autres
peut-être c'est soit aussi
les journalistes alors je l'aurais je
l'ai déjà dit mais j'aurais 50 ans
j'aurais pas écrit ce livre j'aurais pas
osé pourquoi parce que évidemment la
responsabilité des médias de droite et
gauche est énorme parce que c'était eux
qui la signal d'alarme on a ce qui se
passe et inouïe il y a une espèce
d'habitude aujourd'hui de de
valorisation de l'excès outrance de la
violence du mensonge de l'idiotie aussi
franchement on est je donne tout un
chapitre sur ce qui a été écrit par des
intellectuels au moment du covid ça Yuri
sans dédie aussi ahurissant d'idiotie
ces médias qui se gavent des
personnalités très clivantes du clash et
du buzz les Sandrine
vous dites une connerie extremiste vous
êtes un lendemain à la télé il y a des
médias plus responsables que d'autres
c'est pas à moi de dire je pense qu'ils
sont ça fait en plus je fais une part de
responsabilité
vous avez je parle Canal+ vous avez des
gens qui crèvent plus qui travaillent
avec Canal+ qu'on s'est idée j'étais
sceptique moi c'est petit qui ont fait
cette radio leur succès de cette radio
de cette télé puis un type arrive il est
riche il est très très riche il rachète
il dit bon bah très bien je vire ceux
qui sont pas d'accord avec moi et
maintenant vous allez dire l'inverse
mais comment on peut accepter ça comment
accepter que parce qu'on a de l'argent
on prend un journal un média que des
gens ont fait ont imaginé ont créé avec
leurs talent et on dit ça va être
l'inverse parce que moi mon argent
permet de dire que ça va être l'inverse
ça c'est le capitalisme dans ce que ça
pire c'est clair vous dites que c'est un
échec collectif bien sûr il y a les
dirigeants mais pas seulement il y a
aussi le débat d'idée les intellectuels
les journalistes au fond c'est vraiment
une responsabilité collective c'est
aussi une forme d'autocrit ce livre
parce que vous Jean-François Kahn on
s'en souvient vous avez cru au
dépassement du clivage gauche-droite
vous avez cru à l'espace au centre vous
avez cru à tout ça et aujourd'hui il est
toujours là Marine Le Pen le dépassement
du non pas du clivage gauche-droite je
pense qu'il est déplaçable le
dépassement de la gauche tel qu'elle est
devenu et de la droite telle qu'elle est
venue je le pense absolument et je pense
qu'au contraire c'est parce que on a
reculé devant sa dépassement qu'on est
dans une situation des extraits moi vous
savez j'ai fait une expérience
excusez-moi c'est toute la fin du livre
je le publie j'ai fait une expérience
extraordinaire
pour dire ce que je conviens de dire
j'ai trois fois j'ai envoyé une tribune
libre aux filles héros pour dire arrêter
cette surenchère arrêtez d'abord vous
allez faire je l'extrême droite et puis
vous allez tuer la droite trois fois je
fais une tribune libre pour le monde
mais et on dit un nombre pour leur dire
ça la même chose mais si vous continuez
à couvrir les absurdités d'une certaine
gauche les dérives
seront stupéfaits durant comment on
pouvait pas dire ça on pouvait pas
publier ce non pas
je suis sûr que si vous l'avez lu vous
avez été stupéfait de vous absolument
tout y est tout y est dans la dans la
larme en même temps ce qui nous arrive
la montée des extrêmes la montée des
populismes ça arrive à toute l'Europe et
bien au-delà on le voit en Italie avec
mélonie le brexit au Royaume-Uni la
Hongrie la Pologne donc Marine Le Pen
c'est plus quoi un symptôme de quoi dans
ces pays
d'extrême gauche dans ces pays c'est la
mondialisation qui est rejetée partout
en Europe avec ses excès sur la question
économique et sociale sur la question
culturelle aussi c'est
le refus non oui la mondialisation mais
du caractère néo-capitaliste enfin
néolib pas capitaliste néo capitalisme
néolibéral de la mondialisation ça c'est
évident qu'il y a il y a un refus assez
général et puis pour l'extrême gauche
vous savez au Chili au Chili a eu un
mouvement social ça ça fait réfléchir
sur ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il y a
un mouvement social énorme
du coup le gouvernement qui était de
droite le présent de droite a dû
démissionner
aux nouvelles élections un président de
gauche est élu et dit on va faire une
nouvelle constitution parce que
l'ancienne c'était celle de Pinochet et
on vote pour qui va participer à la
commission qui va penser cette
constitution on vote et l'extrême gauche
qui se présente comme des indépendants
donc les gens savent pas que c'est
extrême beaux je suis votre elle est
majoritaire dans dans la commission il
faut une constitution qui est exactement
la constitution que réclame Mélenchon
aujourd'hui pour remplacer ces gammes
publics te dire une constitution
anarchisante pour l'idée des gens
qu'est-ce qui se passe ta fouille
réfléchir qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut
un référendum pour savoir s'ils
acceptent cette constitution refuser à
65%. et ensuite ah bon ben alors il faut
une nouvelle commission vote c'était il
y a deux mois
raz-de-marais d'extrême droite
gauche nourrit
pas par principe mais aujourd'hui vous
expliquer pour vous au fond elles sont
complices c'est les deux phases d'une
même pièce il y a des convergences entre
les extrêmes droites et les extrêmes
gauches expliquez-nous ça je crois
qu'hier du temps du stabilis on aurait
dit il y a une complicité objective bon
mais non il y a pas de compliqué
objective je pensais pas voulu c'est pas
calculé peut-être par une minorité mais
mais il y a en effet à partir du moment
ou une fraction de l'extrême gauche
emploi des moyens qui étaient la
spécificité de l'extrême
forme de violence par exemple ou bien
s'attaquer aux domicile d'un certain
nombre de gens qu'on peut voter comme
vous le souhaitiez ils n'ont pas voté
ils ont voté de façon qui me dérange
j'attaque leur permanence j'attaque bon
par exemple le fait de mettre la race au
centre de toutes les discussions moi
quand il y a 20 ans la gauche comment
dirait excluait qu'on puisse se
référence à la race
aujourd'hui on ne parle que de ça il y a
une référence continue à la religion à
la race aux gens identitaires
comment il y a des vrais similitudes
entre les deux pour vous j'en mets
Jean-Luc Mélenchon marine
que c'est pas la même essence mais oui
on a vu aujourd'hui à l'extrême gauche
et y compris l'extrême gauche
intellectuel on a vu fleurir refleurir
des discours qui naturellement rappelle
ceux qui étaient la spécificité
d'extrême droite alors vous parlez
beaucoup des extrêmes c'est important au
pluriel les extrêmes droites aussi vous
parlez d'Eric Zemmour vous parlez de
Marine Le Pen elle est d'extrême droite
Marine Le Pen elle récuse je pense que
Gémeaux est complètement d'extrême
droite vraiment bah c'est pareil il est
il y a aussi des évolutions moi je
connais bien Zemmour il a même fait des
chroniques dans Marianne au début
l'intérêt que ça soit lui que ça soit
Élisabeth Lévy que ça soit
de véhicules du Figaro qu'est-ce qui les
a fait évoluer extrémisé comme ça ils
étaient pas comme ça ils étaient très
aimés que de vécu ça c'est intéressant
qu'est-ce qui a fait qui s'est
radicalisation qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
l'analyser ben je pense que c'est c'est
en effet une évolution une droiteisation
de la société qui et puis les erreurs il
faut et puis les erreurs de la Gaule le
il y a un type au Figaro ça me fait
marrer parce que dans que entre nous les
un journal comme le monde est un très
bon journal et le Figaro reste un très
bon journal mais leur rubrique débat
enfin la rubrique débat ça doit être la
rubrique on fait discuter des gens qui
sont pas d'accord
c'est l'extrême droite qui des dialogue
avec la droite dure et l'autre c'est
l'extrême gauche qui dialogue avec la
gauche dure
grand journaux peut-être une dernière
question vous avez tout un chapitre sur
la comparaison avec les années 30 vous
savez c'est un peu le point Godwin de
toujours aller chercher des des cadres
historiques pour avoir des repères vous
dites que Marine Le Pen puisse plutôt
dans ce fascisme originel des années 20
que vous voulez vous dire exactement
elle est pertinente cette cette
référence ou pas pour terminer je le dis
dans livre parce que je monte pourquoi
oralement je ne le dis pas pourquoi
parce que les gens ne comprennent pas je
crois pas du tout que que Marine Le Pen
est en tiré publication je pense que les
républicaines je pense en plus que les
pas du tout antisémite je pense qu'elle
est pas une menace en soi pour la
démocratie il serait pas une dictature
je pense que son arrivée au pouvoir
créerait un climat de guerre civile
parce que ça encouragerait l'extrémisme
inverse
certains à l'extrême gauche c'est ce que
vous laissez entendre aller jusque là
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
qu'elle a compris c'est sa force que la
fait confluer des revendications
classiques de l'extrême droite tout le
sur la sécurité des migrations d'Alban
avec des revendications qui venaient
plutôt de l'extrême gauche de remise en
cause du capitalisme et sincère
d'ailleurs chez elle je crois
ça rappelle en effet mais les gens l'ont
oublié ce qui était le fasciste des
années 20 en Italie la force de
Mussolini qui venait de l'extrême gauche
vous signale c'était d'avoir fait cette
convergence entre ces deux ces deux
sentiments en tout cas c'est passionnant
de vous entendre oralement mais aussi de
vous lire parce que je le disais il y a
énormément de références historiques
pour essayer de comprendre le temps
présent et les dangers
l'extrémisme tué également
il faut pas les laisser gagner dans ces
cas-là parce que la musique c'est trop
important